[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Mark Sanchez Fox NFL analyst former NFL
and USC quarterback your reaction when
you heard that uh Tom Brady was finally
finally retiring
yeah I think uh same as
same as last year but most importantly I
mean you just
welcoming him to the team I guess for
the first time right
um and I guess thanks for for ruining
the trajectory of my career for the
second time Tom wow you know I get
drafted to the guy's division now he's
got to come
come to Fox and
ruin everything here so I'm just
you know I can't get away from the guy
so you think obviously I'm saying that
in Jess that he's he's the man he's the
best of all time and I'm fired up to
have him uh that's that's pretty cool
and um hopefully he doesn't get too
annoyed with The Hazing that we put him
through as rookie Sheriff Fox this can
be rough for him uh when You Face Brady
that was they didn't he have a nine year
window when he didn't win a Super Bowl
yeah something like that he took a
little break and then came back
pretty strong I'd say yeah that was like
the second round
um the second Hall of Fame career kind
of thing
so do you talk at all I know you you've
said this before because you were able
to play him and you know you guys had
some success but do you do you talk at
all pre you know prior to the game
pregame I know you hug it out after the
after the game but any conversation at
all
uh
not real I mean that dude was like he
was mysterious right and
um guys like you know Jordan Kobe
that caliber of player like Tom
when you're at the top of the game
like it was hard to just get video like
I'd go work out in the off season
there'd be a video online like that
Tom goes and he must have had some
device that just shut off cell phone
service for like a mile radius right
because nobody saw what he did nobody
talked about what he did it was just
like he did everything in secret and he
wasn't going to give anything away until
he started the whole tb12 like hey
here's the diet here's the workout stuff
and he started you know guys towards the
end of their career they bring along
young guys or they Mentor young guys or
whatever but when they're still getting
to the Mountaintop and kind of
establishing themselves
they don't give away anything
everything's tight to the vest and um so
you know when I'm competing against the
guy in New York
dude you can't you don't even know it's
like uh it's like usual suspects Kaiser
Soze he's just like where is this guy
who is this guy you see him all the time
but you don't really and then he just
shows up for the game and you know it's
it's incredible to uh to watch the
trajectory of his career in 22 years or
whatever it's been that's that's
unbelievable he had three Hall of Fame
careers within one career mark
right it's you know and people ask all
the time like what sets them apart why
is he so different why what what is it
about him and I think
um you know it's this ability he has one
to like block out distractions but two
to never get bored
and that's really hard for quarterbacks
like they get to a certain point and
it's like yeah I got a guy open in the
flat but I'm gonna you know I'm gonna
try and fit this ball in down the field
or gosh this would be my third or fourth
touchdown in the game or whatever like
this dude was just wired different and
he had this laser focused and uh you
know I've heard this from coaches I've
heard this from people in military
backgrounds you don't suddenly get to
these big games where the stakes are
high and you know everybody's excited
and all that and there's there's all
this build up and you don't suddenly
become faster smarter stronger quicker
more arm strength more accurate like
those things don't just show up on Game
Day right you don't rise to any occasion
I'm a firm believer that that is not
real you sink to the level of your
training you become who you've always
been in those moments and who that guy
has always been is somebody who's never
been bored with the mundane the footwork
going over his drops understanding his
weight distribution and disassociating
his hips and shoulders and chucking the
ball downfield consistently he was a guy
who like invented working out in your
football pads in the off season nobody
else did that before him and
um you know that kind of
regimen and that kind of dedication to
something without getting bored there's
something to that you're you're wired a
little different to be able to focus
like that for that long of a period and
sustain success that long if Brady is
the number one quarterback of all time
who's number two
gosh so it was so funny people were
debating that the other day and
obviously like I think there's some sort
of algorithm you can come in come here
my little man's getting ready for school
so we have one question for him here
come on this side quick quick
watch
this is unsolicited okay and this is for
dinner or no dinner okay who's better
Tom Brady or dada
dada okay we got dinner tonight
that was good conditioning
um all right so who's number two
well you gotta I think there's this
algorithm of like there's a certain
amount of points that should be allotted
to Super Bowl wins because some of that
is used some of that is the team because
look at somebody like Ben Roethlisberger
the first Super Bowl he didn't do as
much he didn't throw a touchdown Antoine
Randall l through the touchdown they
were built more like we were my rookie
year in 2009 like they were a run first
defensive team the biggest play Ben made
was probably saving the tackle on the
fumble for Jerome Bettis like that was
probably his biggest play but then later
on Ben Roethlisberger's throwing for 5
000 yards in a season throwing six
touchdown passes in consecutive games so
like is Ben up there being what is he
two and one or yeah two and one in Super
Bowls I think or one-on-one whatever it
is where's Terry Bradshaw where's Joe
Montana where's Elway went to however
many Super Bowls won two at the end and
left where's Peyton Manning where's Eli
he went two for two in Super Bowl so I
think Super Bowls are something I think
all Pros are something I think
um
the uh MVP category because then where
do you go there in Rogers he's you know
he's only been to one but he won it
then where's Roger Staubach you know so
oh God it's
I I mean Tom's one for sure and then
where do you put a guy like Patrick
Mahomes who's like already on this crazy
trajectory he's about to if he wins he's
two and one in Super Bowls which is
better than a bunch of guys he's already
been to multiple championship games
that's all he knows either the
championship game loss or a Super Bowl
like where does that guy fit you know
and it's only six years in so is she a
top 10 quarterback of all time right now
who homes
I think 10 is probably Fair only because
it's such a small sample size right like
if you never if he wins this Super Bowl
and never played another down
he's got to be top ten but if I think if
I said ability
oh just now now I was changing the
question to now if I just said pure
ability playing the position
because because you know Brady's not
necessarily number one
yeah I wouldn't say he's
the most talented quarterback all of all
time is who
I'd still say Rogers is right there I'd
still say Mahomes is probably right
there but they're part of this new style
of game the Elway would be in there too
for me
no doubt because of the way he could
throw it almost like these guys in a
world where they didn't throw it like
this but
um ability wise shoot I mean you're not
dudes who could just straight sling The
Rock where's Mourinho where's uh Philip
Rivers where's
um you know Brett Favre
um God like dudes who could just flat
out launch it throw it literally like
through someone's body into the guy they
want like those guys are there's only a
few a few of those guys that come around
um you know every few years and they are
like you know the ball just jumps out of
their hand looks like a jugs machine you
know that's those that's some special
talent he's Mark Sanchez Fox NFL analyst
former quarterback of course
help me understand what Sean Payton's
role will be in particular specifically
with Russell Wilson
like yeah I keep hearing that he's going
to fix him
what is going to be fixed
well fix is
um you know I didn't look at his final
rankings this year where Russ was I'm
sure you guys have a better idea of that
um but like if you do this case study
obviously the last two seasons for Russ
have probably been his worst
but I think there's plenty to learn from
those situations and he has plenty to
fall back on from his prior success I
think one of the huge things for Coach
Payton to figure out and uh we're
actually supposed to do this Super Bowl
show I'm curious if he's going to be
there on Monday we're supposed to do the
show with Carissa Thompson me and Sean
Payton on the on the panel and then
um
uh Glazer is going to be in Arizona when
the teams arrive at the arena or
wherever they show up and it's like a
hole to do on Fox's show like this
arrival show yeah I don't know if Sean's
gonna be there I had so many questions
for him if now you might be gone
um but if he's there I'm gonna wear them
out for you and get all the info
um but I just think
the biggest thing like when you get a
new coordinator is like you gotta like
strip them down
figure out you know from your
perspective as a coordinator what what
does this guy do well right and make
sure we at least have those in the
system and then what can I teach him
based on what he does well where can we
go what's the ceiling for us without
overloading them and without you know
you got to almost get to the bottom of
get to the truth of what happened the
last couple years where were you
uncomfortable why did this happen you
have to go watch some of that tape
together in my opinion and then you know
Turn the page on that whole deal and now
it's we're moving forward we're going to
spend our couple days couple weeks
whatever it takes for them to get to a
starting point and that's kind of like
the the precursor the the Prelude to
this whole deal and then it's full steam
ahead this is what we do this is how we
do it here's exactly what our
progressions reads footwork are you do
that I can set you up for success and
remember both of these guys have been
successful
and have sustained success for a long
period of time so I think there's plenty
of meat on the bone there
um and you know that kind of a new coach
like that I mean it reinvigorates a
locker room they know where he's coming
from it's NFC Championship appearances
it's playoff wins it's a Super Bowl win
with Drew Brees a guy who's not the
tallest guy in the world I'm sure that
has to make Russ feel pretty good I mean
Drew Drew could sling it from the pocket
and you know he's bumping six feet I
know he's listed at 6-1 but he's like
barely there you know and that guy was
deadly from the pocket so Russ had that
hasn't been Russ's strong suit but Sean
Payton's one of the best pocket passing
coordinators maybe of all time I mean
this guy can dial him up and it's the
sequencing it's protecting the
quarterback from himself at times and
that's the job of a coordinator so it's
it will be interesting and God I hope
he's on that show on Monday because I
really want to talk to him
um I I can ask this two different ways
which quarterback has them most to gain
in this Super Bowl or which quarterback
has the most to lose in this Super Bowl
I don't know if
because Mahomes has been so established
already I think this just reaffirms
who he is his ability what he does his
trajectory I think for someone like
Jalen hurts he's got a little more to
gain
because this is like puts him on that
map you know it puts him on that
pedestal of hey dude I was counted out
in College lost my job boom went over
you know Oklahoma we know the story kind
of snubbed and the draft felt like he
should have been a first round pick was
it you know am I a starter am I backup
am I legitimate franchise quarterback
I think this knocks out a lot of doubt
and then only raises the the bar for him
and now it becomes the expectation like
okay it's no longer a question if you're
a legitimate starter it is okay now
you're the guy you got that Super Bowl
in your back pocket let's see what you
can do again can you be exhaust Ely
quarterback who wins multiple Super
Bowls and that would then he's on in
that you know trajectory in that that
conversation of being one of the best if
they can duplicate this but
um got some of the story lines between
the Kelsey brothers and Andy Reid going
back against his old Squad I mean this
is this is one of the
like coolest Super Bowls I can think of
storyline one this is like this is it
this is a really good one and I guess
the other thing I love about these two
quarterbacks is
the the way the teams rally around them
you know like you see these guys doing
the post game interview and guys go out
of their way to make sure they like
scream at the reporter the poor reporter
is trying to get an answer after the
game and into the camera like this is
our dog this is our guy we ride or die
for this dude no matter what whatever
Direction he's going I'm going right
behind I'm getting in line and going
right behind him because I know he's the
man and both quarterbacks have that
they've they have it they have whatever
it is that you need to move these men
into the right formation Direction get
them to score get them fired up and
rally and that is that is fun to watch
it's it's really like a master class on
on leadership and and being the man
being the quarterback in all facets of
your life finish this sentence if the
Bengals and Joe burrow had won that game
uh I was in some ways I was hoping for
it for Joe if the Bengals
and Joe Barrow had won that game they're
in the Super Bowl I don't know I think
uh but he he now
back-to-back Super Bowls you've beaten
Mahomes again you beat him in Kansas
City again you know now you're moving
into a different category if you're Joe
burrow
I think it would have yeah it would
definitely would have put him in a
different category because then you get
the second appearance but you know the
biggest thing is like
and it's unfortunate the way things work
out at times but like if you don't win
the Super Bowl you know it's it's not
like you're unsuccessful there's
different levels to success like you can
argue what is success what's not you're
already an NFL quarterback like that's
successful okay fine but if you're
talking about the top of the top it's
like the same reason and I omitted for
no you know purposeful reason but you
know we didn't say Jim Kelly when we
were talking about all those players
yeah and it's you go to all those super
bowls and you lose whatever the
circumstances may be could have played
his best in a game we could play his
worst whatever they whatever you lose if
Peyton Manning never won a Super Bowl
were you sing a different tune about the
guy and it's unfortunate so I think the
biggest thing for him is not only
getting back there but you know
overcoming that
you know that that thing you know Steve
Young dealt with it for years because he
backed up Montana and then he's got to
win the Super Bowl so when you do it
really establishes yourself and then now
you're duking it out with a bunch of
different guys in Gold jackets and okay
who has more who has more Rings this
that and the other but that is like the
top of the top so the the biggest thing
too for a franchise like Cincinnati is
shot's on goal like shots in the
tournament one getting in the postseason
two seasons in a row they've made deep
runs now is this who they are if it is
they're gonna they're gonna mess around
and beat somebody end up in the Super
Bowl and then you roll the dice but
that's that's essentially what it was
for the Patriots for almost 20 years
we're in the tournament you know the
divisions ours we're in the tournament
now let's see how far we can go and some
of that circumstantial based on injuries
and whatever you play a team that's
really hot you run into a buzz saw what
are you gonna do it happens but
you just want shots on goal you want
attempts and I think the Bengals are on
the right track
did Rex Ryan ever tell the defense do
whatever it takes to take Brady out
um
I'm sure I mean Rex is the kind of guy
like I didn't sit in all the defensive
meetings but
um Rex is the kind of guy just assumed
like
fight you in the parking lot before the
game kind of deal and uh whatever
happens like that's just the way it's
gonna be but he also came from a
different pedigree of football like his
dad you know his dad's notorious for you
know his players being out all night
before the game and you know whatever
they're doing during the week and dude
you show up at one o'clock on Sunday
and when I got no beef with you dude if
you're here to do your job I don't
really care what you do but he wouldn't
feel now Bounty out on Brady would he no
no no no I I never no I never heard that
okay yeah just curious
could have definitely didn't want him in
the game yeah you could have said yes
that's true whatever circumstances
exactly like I'm not saying cheap shot
him but if you happen to not be in the
game that'd be great you know yeah uh
you know we knocked out bledsoed and
look what happened you know exactly they
wouldn't have done that changed history
uh great to talk to you thank you for
your insights as always
absolutely appreciate you guys that's
Mark Sanchez Fox NFL analyst and of
course former quarterback